today on the Matt Walsh show the media
is pushing for a one-size-fits-all
approach to the coronavirus epidemic but
a few states in the country have refused
so far to issue stay at home orders and
are doing things a little bit
differently approving why the
one-size-fits-all approach doesn't work
but why is it why is it that so many
people especially in the media and some
in government are so desperate for every
single state to adopt the same approach
I have a theory about that that I'll
share also five headlines including some
of the most desperate and absurd
fear-mongering that we have yet seen
from the media and today we cancel
Alyssa Milano who went from as you
recall a champion of the me2 movement
saying believe all women to calling for
due process for men nothing wrong with
calling for due process I think that's
the right thing but what is it exactly
that changed her mind all of a sudden
that's the reason that she gets
cancelled we'll talk about all that
coming up all right so starting off the
media has for the last several days been
badgering the remaining states in the
country that have not issued state home
orders statewide state home owners
although some of those states do have
individual cities that have their own
state home owners the media really
really really wants every state to get
on board and go you know full-on
lockdown with this reporters have been
harassing Trump about it at the White
House press conferences saying why don't
you institute a national lockdown and
force every state to adopt a state home
order and well I could tell you one of
the reasons why he doesn't do it and
shouldn't do it is that it would be
wildly unconstitutional to state that
the the president absolutely does not
have the authority to tell every single
person in the country to stay in their
homes but but the media doesn't care
about that of course they've been
publishing article after article trying
to shame these states the few remaining
states for not having stayed homeowners
so for example CBS com says 43 states
now have state homeowners for
chronovisor there are seven that don't
NPR states without coronavirus lockdown
orders are under scrutiny USA Today
in states without state homeowners
Americans celebrate freedom as death
toll climbs Forbes here are the nine
state governors who have refused to
issue state homeowners MSN coronavirus
in the US how all 50 states are
responding and why nine states still
refused to issue state homeowners New
York Times holdout states resist call
for state homeowners what are they
waiting for now if you're wondering
which states are the holdouts the
naughty children The Selfish Psychopaths
on a mission to spread the contagion and
destroy mankind
well reporter from NBC has helpfully
listed them so that we can point to them
and shame them for their for being so
reckless his tweet says the eight
governor's who have so I guess it's down
to eight now the eight governors who
have not issued state homeowners
Arkansas ASA Hutchinson Iowa Kim
Reynolds Nebraska Pete Ricketts North
Dakota Doug burgum South Dakota Christie
know'm South Carolina Henry McMaster
Utah gary Herbert Wyoming mark Gordon
okay so those are those are the states
that don't have the state homers and
we're supposed to be very angry at these
states how dare you how dare you
wagging our finger at them let's let's
take a look at this because this is
interesting they haven't gone into a
full lockdown media says they should
let's let's look at their individual
situations and I want to focus
especially on three of these states
because the absurdity of the push for a
national lockdown and a
one-size-fits-all approach to this this
situation can be seen especially in
these three states now it could be seen
in some of the others too don't get me
wrong I mean Arkansas has for example
927 cases only 16 deaths in a population
of 3 million Utah has about 1600 cases
13 deaths in a population of about 3
million so you know III would say there
there's there's just no justification
there's no reason for a full statewide
lockdown there is not yet a an emergency
situation there but then what about
South Dakota North Dakota and
Wyoming the media is pushing for lock
downs in South Dakota North Dakota and
Wyoming are those states actually in the
midst of a coronavirus emergency is
there any reason for them to go into a
lockdown well let's see South Dakota has
288 cases and four deaths in a
population of 880 mm spread out over
77,000 square miles North Dakota has 225
cases by the way these are the numbers
that's based on the last report which
was yesterday Wyoming has 212 cases zero
deaths in a population of 577 thousand
in a state that covers ninety seven
thousand square miles
well what else am I missing at North
Dakota so I gave South Dakota that's 288
cases four deaths North Dakota 225 cases
three deaths population of 760 thousand
over seventy thousand square miles and
then I said in Wyoming zero deaths 212
cases population of 577 thousand almost
a hundred thousand square miles that
population is spread out over so what's
our grand total that would be between
all three states seven total coronavirus
deaths amid 2.2 million people over two
hundred and forty four thousand square
miles seven deaths and the media saying
they should go into a full-on
stay-at-home lockdown now let's compare
that just to put this into perspective
here because I think sper spective is
really being lost that's the one thing
we might be missing the most right now
is perspective so perspective let's look
at let's compare this to New York City
New York City has been obviously as we
know very hard hit and many people not
just in the media seem to think that
every state should react to the virus
the same way that New York City is
reacting every state should treat the
problem the way New York City is
treating it
we should according to these people just
sort of assume that what's happening in
New York can and will happen everywhere
else in the country well New York has 8
million people
packed into 300 square miles okay so
that's two million people in two hundred
and forty four thousand square miles in
Wyoming South Dakota North Dakota as
opposed to 8 million people in 300
square miles
New York packs 27,000 people into each
square mile of its city there are there
are more people in 3 square square miles
of New York than there are in the entire
capital city of North Dakota which is
Bismarck which is 31 square miles by the
way what's the point here the point is
that different parts of the country are
in very very different situations and
insisting that every part of the country
meet this complex challenge in the exact
same way is total absolute unabashed
lunacy it makes no sense
there is no reason no reason at all why
Wyoming with zero coronavirus deaths
should respond in the same way as New
York with 3,000 that's like saying that
that every state in the country should
adopt the exact same policies and
strategies to deal with you know the
homeless homelessness I mean you take
any any problem at all but it's like
saying that every state should deal with
homelessness in the exact same way well
you wouldn't say that because doesn't
your strategy for homelessness really
depend quite a bit on how prevalent the
problem is and where it is and how the
homeless people are distributed it's
very specific to your a situation in
your state or in your city would it make
sense for the state of Montana with 1300
or so homeless people in the entire
state to pretend for the sake of
battling the problem that it's exactly
like New York no although incidentally
Montana is pretending that it's exactly
like New York when it comes to the virus
Montana has been on a full lockdown now
for weeks that the current lockdown I
think is supposed to supposedly end on
April 10th but they're already talking
about extending it by three weeks so
they're on a full lockdown they only
have three hundred deaths in six or 300
cases rather three hundred cases and six
deaths yet Montana went
Lock them many states are in a similar
position having locked down even though
there's no coronavirus epidemic in their
states there is not an epidemic in every
single state in the country
Minnesota is under a state home order
yet it has only 29 deaths with a median
age of death of 86 this raises the
question why are so many people
especially in the media desperate for
these other states to lock down when you
just look at the numbers and you look at
the situation it's very obvious that
whatever North Dakota South Dakota
Wyoming Arkansas whatever these states
are Utah whatever these states are doing
it seems to be fine it seems to be
working pretty well I mean the situation
in Wyoming is almost as good as it could
possibly be when nobody's died of it
yeah they have 200 cases but you're
gonna have a few right so it'd be
difficult for it to be much better in
Wyoming with respect to the quarter
virus than it currently is so logically
you would look at it and say well
whatever they're doing seems to be okay
there's no evidence that their strategy
isn't working so what's the point though
why would you say well we still we need
you to lock down we need you to decimate
your economy go ahead and destroy your
statewide economy 4-0 deaths and if a
state's gonna lock down based on 0
deaths from a disease then why wouldn't
it remain locked down forever because of
all the other diseases that haven't
killed anybody in their state or only
have killed a few people doesn't make
sense why does the media insist and what
let's just on it well I I agree with
what some others have have postulated
that one of the reasons a big reason is
this the media doesn't want a control
group the last thing they want is to
have states that act essentially as
control groups in this national
experiment that were all forced to be a
part of or most of us are forced to be a
part of
because if these other states make it
through okay despite not having locked
down then it will prove that there was
another way of handling this that lock
downs are not necessarily necessary for
every state but if everybody locks down
then it's a win-win for the media
because if the virus doesn't end up
being as bad as they said which already
we know that it's not as bad as they
said but if that if that holds true if
that trend continues then they can just
say well the lockdown saved us you see
yeah because if every single state is
locked down and then with the success in
every single state we could say that's
because of the lock downs but if it is
as bad as they say then they could say
see we needed locked up so they win
either way but that's a harder case to
make if you've got these outliers these
other states who don't lock down and yet
have survived quite easily throughout
the ordeal so this this push in this
call for a national lockdown for these
other states to get on board as they're
saying this has nothing to do with
safety it has nothing to do with beating
the virus or whatever this is about
people who have been fear-mongering who
don't want to be proven wrong and the
bureaucrats and people in government who
are pushing for this for them it's about
control and for the media it's about
narrative so for the for the government
it's about control for the media it's
about narrative alright let's move on to
your headlines and staying now on the
subject of the media here they go again
with the corona virus and battlefield
death comparisons which they love to do
the USA Today this is a headline for the
USA Today it says 10,000 people in the
US have died because of the corona virus
more than the more than the number of
battle deaths from six u.s. wars
combined
okay now remember we have been told over
and over and over again that you must
not compare the corona virus to the flu
comparing coronavirus deaths to flu
deaths is completely inappropriate and
because these are two things are totally
different and they're under
related and so that analogy doesn't work
and it makes no sense so if you were to
say that you know during a normal flu
season like 50,000 people died and so
far 10,000 of Dimes of credit virus that
you're a terrible person if you say that
terrible person you're trying to you're
trying to minimize the quarter virus
you're trying to get people killed
you're killing everybody's grandparents
you can't do that but you can compare
the corona virus to wars because somehow
the comparison to the war is is more
relevant than a comparison to another
virus okay by the way what wars are they
talking about because you think six US
wars combined 10,000 deaths that what
wars I mean we can't be talking about
like World War two here well no the war
is that they're that they're that
they're combining to get to this scary
figure are the American Revolution the
war of 1812 the Mexican War Indian Wars
spanish-american war and and Desert
Storm this is what they've stooped to
they're actually comparing coronavirus
deaths to deaths in the war of 1812
that's what they're doing this is how
desperate they become in their quest to
find scary ways of framing the numbers
that they're now they're now digging
back in history and frantically
searching through Wikipedia and fight
you war of 1812 let's go with that why
not I mean why not the Barbary the first
Barbary war how about that
let's let's let's compare think it was
like 30 people 30 Americans died in that
three hundred times as many Americans
have died from coronavirus has died in
the first Barbary war now it would be
kind of hilarious if not for the subject
matter and of course you know the point
here is that you could pull this kind of
move with anything to make it seem
scarier I could say accurately probably
I don't have the numbers in front of
evil this is probably true that falling
coconuts have killed more people than
John Wayne Gacy Ted Bundy of the DC
snipers combined I could say that it's
probably statistically true
but what would be the point of saying
that that is that's a comparison that
makes no sense and is not helpful and
does not lend any perspective at all to
the threat of falling coconuts in fact
it puts it out of perspective
number two and well ladies and gentlemen
your dystopian future has officially
arrived watch this now I should note
here and I'm not I'm not sure if this
makes it creepier or less creepy
probably more creepy that the FAA has no
idea who was behind that drone the New
York Police Department says that it
wasn't then so we cook we don't actually
know who that was someone's sending that
dystopian weird Orwellian drone out to
warn the citizens about the corner of
ours nobody knows who did it right now
number three there was a line of cars
take a look at this picture line of cars
literally miles long in South Florida
waiting at a food bank and here's a you
see you see there I mean these are these
are people waiting for food from a food
bank called feeding South Florida and
feeding South Florida says that they've
seen a 600 percent increase the number
of people asking for food over the last
couple of weeks 600 percent this is not
the only line like this we've seen
around the country so just so you know
when you have lines at food banks
stretching miles to the horizon that is
not a sign of a coming economic crash
that's a sign that you are already in an
economic crash people are talking about
the economic crash as if it's a thing
that might happen no it is something
that is happening right now and every
single marker that you look at starting
with on the unemployment numbers tells
you that number four I almost feel bad
playing this for you because it's become
a daily thing and I'm not interested
really of making fun of a guy who has
dementia but at the same time this is
not about making fun of them this is
this is about this is a guy who wants to
be President United States and is
clearly losing his mind so here
Joe Biden of course we're talking about
on MSNBC last night we have to do at
least several things one we have to
depend on what the president's going to
do right now and first of all he has to
tell wait till the cases before anything
happens with look the whole idea is he's
got to get in place things that were
shortages of okay so just the the
transcript of that he said one we have
to depend on what the president's going
to do right now and first of all he has
to tell uh wait till the case is before
anything happens look the whole idea is
he's got to get in place things that
were shortages of this really is just
like we played yesterday I don't even
I'm not trying to be difficult or
flipping I I I don't know what he's
trying to say here and the thing is you
when someone is speaking off-the-cuff on
camera and you want to be a jerk about
it you could very often find a
transcript of a certain segment of what
they said and it looks nonsensical on
the page because maybe they were
fumbling over the words or they were
they were kind of waiting for the next
thought to come to them so you could do
that to anybody you could certainly do
it to me but in this case this is not
fumbling over the words this is pure
nonsense the whole idea is he's got to
get in place things that were shortages
of see that that's that's not the kind
of sentence you say when you're tripping
and stumbling and kind of maybe thrown
for a loop and the answer you're giving
this is something you say when you're
when there's a when there's something
there's something wrong when there's a
disconnect in your brain which is what's
happening with Joe Biden number five
finally and back to the theme of media
scaremongering here's the headline from
The Daily Mail okay very scary headline
it says new evidence amid fears
coronavirus can hide in human cells and
reactivates the virus can reactivate
after you've recovered that's that's the
headline and there's evidence of that
they're saying wow that's that sounds
very scary maybe start thinking
it's like all these people have
recovered because they still die maybe
or is there it just sounds like scary
stuff and what the way the game is
played is you know what what what these
outlets would prefer for you do what
Daily Mail wants you to do is read the
headline and maybe click on it for just
click on it for a second and read like
the first sentence so that they get to
click but then click right out they
don't want you actually read the entire
article because when you do here's what
you find and I'll read for you from this
Daily Mail article remember remember
remember what the headline was new
evidence amid fierce coronavirus can
hide a human cells reactivate ok here's
what the actual article says 51 patients
who recovered from coronavirus in South
Korea have tested positive again raising
fears the virus can be reactivated still
sounds pretty scary right the patients
from the country's worst hit city were
put in quarantine after being diagnosed
with a virus then tested positive again
days after being released Korea Center
for Disease Control prevention said the
virus was likely reactivated rather than
patients being reinfected scientists of
the government-run health body believed
the virus may lay dormant and
undetectable levels in the human cells
they say that for unknown reasons the
viral particles can be reactivated but
it is unclear if patients become
infectious again ok so that's so we've
read that far and this is the point
where you're supposed to drop off you've
read enough you've kind of got you've
got you've got the gist of it now you
can share it and you can spread the fear
like wildfire helped to spread it all
over the Internet
if you keep going though one more
sentence here's what you'll read experts
say there is no evidence to prove that
the virus acts in this way and studies
and monkeys have actually shown the
opposite and they say in cases where
patients produce a positive result twice
it is normally because of a test giving
the wrong result which happens one in
five times so that's so you you go
through the first you several sentences
and in the headline and then you get to
the bottom of the article that negates
everything you just read basically that
said since I just read really what the
sentence says is forget everything you
just read before
none of this is probably true the
headline was new evidence and in the
article it says there is no evidence so
there's new evidence and the new
evidence is there's no evidence so what
the real story is that there are some
people in South Korea who tested
positive and then test the negative and
tested positive again and there are some
unnamed people in government in South
Korea who are worried who have fears
that this means that the virus can
reactivate but in terms of the actual
science and the studies and in the
research there's no evidence of that
whatsoever and there's a real there's
there's a much much simpler explanation
which is just that the negative test
that they took was wrong and that
happens 20% of the time so it would make
sense that you're gonna have they say 51
people well that makes sense the fact
that there are fears among some unknown
people of some thing habakkuk that's not
it that's not a news story I have all
kinds of fears you want to do a you want
to do a new story about fears that I
have I have all kinds of irrational
fears when I go on airplanes I mean I've
got tons of fears and airplanes and now
I can add a few because of the
coronavirus thing one of my irrational
fears on an airplane you know what I
worry about sometimes is that is that
the plane will go too high and will like
drift into outer space which is
completely impossible and only a [ __ ]
can worry about that
so it's physically impossible that could
happen right but it's a fear that I it's
just a totally irrational fear so why
not do it why not do a news article
headline new fears that airplanes fly
too high and hit the moon new fears I've
actually I've had a life had I've had
dreams that I had this weird recurring
dream of things that are like elevators
- this weird recurring dream is my whole
life where I'm in an elevator and you
would think a normal recurring nightmare
is where you're an elevator that crashes
it hits the ground my fears I mean in in
my dreams the elevator
- hi and kind of shoots out the top of
the building I don't know what that says
about me psychologically nothing good
probably alright let's move on to your
daily cancelation before we do I want to
remind you again about our all-access
live shows that if you haven't checked
it out yet head over to daily wire.com
at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
and this of course is we've been telling
you about it's just a sort of more
relaxed and relaxed kind of
conversational vibe as opposed to our
normal programming so it's not as much
of a formal sort of show and this is all
about breaking up the isolation of being
in quarantine and being shut down and
we've moved up that's why we moved up
the timeline and we started doing the
the all-access shows now by then we were
supposed to be waiting and doing it a
few months from now originally for just
the all-access members but it's open now
for at least for now - daily why are
members all daily wired members so take
advantage of that and if you're around
today at 8 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific 5
p.m. Pacific make sure to tune in for
that ok today we are canceling Alyssa
Milano Alyssa Milano is the me to
champion the champion of for abused
women this is a person who has valiantly
stood up to hold so many alleged sexual
assaulters accountable even even when
there is no evidence against the alleged
sexual assaulters like with like with
Kavanagh but what Alyssa Milano has said
many times effectively is the evidence
doesn't matter and if a man's accused
let's just assume he's guilty and tear
him down well Milano funny enough
endorsed Joe Biden and then Joe Biden
was accused of sexually assaulting a
woman in 1993 and does that mean that
she'll now disavow abide in and link
arms again with the me2 movement and
it's insist that he drop out and be
arrested well no not quite here she is
on the show Andy Cohen live explaining
why she is not disavowing Joe Biden and
why she has gone through a rather
drastic change of perspective listen to
this I believe that um even though we
should believe women and that is an
important thing and what there
statement really means is like you know
for so long the the goto has been not to
believe them so really we have to sort
of societally change that mindset to
believing women but that does not mean
at the expense of not you know giving
men their due process whoa okay hold on
a second wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold the
phone
due process what are you talking about
do you want to get due process when did
this happen
I don't think we've heard Alyssa
Milano's say the phrase due process
nobody in the me2 movement has uttered
the phrase due process at any point I
was beginning to think they never heard
it I was beginning to think that they
that they had no idea what it meant like
if you if you said the phrase due
process to them they would think it has
something to do with with the rain
droplets that you see on the grass in
the morning in the summer you know the
do the due process is how the dew gets
on the grass or something but now she's
a legal scholar constitutional scholar
talking about due process well that's
really funny because because she
actually went to DC during the Kavanaugh
hearings and she attended the hearings
and do you think she attended the
hearings to support due process do you
think she was carrying a sign that said
something like give this man due process
no I'm afraid not in fact take a look at
this tweet it says I'm in DC because I
don't believe any man's misogyny should
take precedent over a survivors humanity
we tried to see Murkowski Collins in
hyde-smith today and share our stories
of survival they refused to see us and
then she's holding a sign that says I
believe survivors so she went from I
believe survivors to give men their due
process and all it took to make that
switch was for her favorite politician
to be accused that's all it took and
let's be clear about something that it's
not as though there's really solid
evidence or there was really solid
evidence against Kavanaugh whereas there
isn't any against Joe Biden even if that
was the case that shouldn't matter
because Alyssa Milano and all the me to
improve people
they their point was never about
evidence whether there's evidence or no
evidence completely irrelevant the point
is believe women evidence or not but as
it happens as far as evidence goes there
was none at all against Kavanagh
none just Christine Ford's word and
against Biden Biden there's a little bit
of evidence arguably there are two
people who say they were told by Tara
Reid the accuser at the time when the
incident happened back in 1993 I think
it was her her brother and a friend I'm
pretty sure and they have confirmed that
they were told in 1993 by her that she
was assaulted so that's circumstantial
evidence at least it's more than
Christine for debt so that sight this is
not about evidence at all let's let's
hear a little bit more from Milano
explaining her thinking her it's got to
be fair in both directions okay you know
I've been very vocal about Biden and my
support for for him I've known him for a
long time and I did do my due diligence
due diligence because part of it was
that and the the article that sort of
stood out to me was that times up I
decided not to take the case and so you
know it was important to you that that
meant well maybe there's more to this
story here right I did my work and I and
I spoke to times up and I just don't
feel comfortable throwing away a decent
man that I've known for 15 years yep
in this in this time of complete chaos
without there being a thorough
investigation sure that mainstream media
would be jumping all over this as well
if if you know if they weren't in a or
if there was more if there was more
credible if there was
evidence that was if they found more
evidence everything she's saying right
now is totally reasonable if she was in
a normal circumstance if it wasn't for
the fact that she was aligned with the
me2 movement and had spent the last two
or three years of her life trying to
tear men down based on no evidence and
and you're coming out so strongly
against due process over the last few if
it wasn't for that I would say far from
being cancelled for this she should be
applauded because everything she's
saying in a vacuum makes sense yeah you
should have due process and yeah if you
if you know somebody and you've known
him for a long time and you know their
character that doesn't mean that they it
that they're not capable of doing
something horrible so it's not that in
itself is not decisive but yeah if you
know somebody in your friend with them
friends friends of theirs and they're
accused and there's little to no
evidence all right I don't think you
should just immediately drop them like a
hot potato and assume that everything
you've learned about them as a friend is
irrelevant or not true so that is all
fine in a vacuum but we're not in a
vacuum and the problem is that Alyssa
Milano came to this realization only
because of her favorite politician
getting accused and I can't even really
call it a realization because it's not
as though she's saying hey listen all
the stuff with Cavanaugh I think we were
wrong about that in fact I think the
whole meet to movement has long since
gone off the rails and so this is not a
sort of come to Jesus moment where she's
apologizing and nothing nothing like
that at all so this realization I'm
guessing is limited only to Joe Biden
and the next time a conservative a
Republican or someone that she doesn't
like is accused she's gonna jump right
back on the YouTube bandwagon again so
that's why Alyssa Milano was canceled
let's go to emails you can email show it
by becoming a daily while remember you
can access the mailbag that way this is
from Andrew says hi Matt it's I thought
you'd find how North Dakota is running
pretty interesting
we just talked about that I live in a
relatively rural area the nearest
Walmart is an hour away and most people
are still able to work schools bars and
restaurants are still shut down besides
takeout but almost everything else is
still open most if not all businesses
have changed how they operate for
example banks or drive-through only for
99% of the time and face to face by
appointment in necessity only I'm a
farmer and our parts stores have changed
too calling in and ordering what you
need and having an employee bring it out
to you other stores have buffer setup so
you can only go to the counter and the
employees basically do the shopping for
you it's definitely not perfect but it's
allowed most businesses to remain in
operation sorry for the rambling but I
thought I'd let you know how we're doing
things would be differently granted I
know we have a much lower population
density than most places PS thanks for
being one of the few voices standing up
to government overreach in our lives and
our churches we haven't been forced to
shut down churches here yet even though
almost all have volunteered to do so if
we're ordered to if we're if we are
ordered to their will 100% be
underground church services do you think
once ordered to keep churches closed we
have the obligation to have services I
think it's a conversation worth having
to answer your last question no I don't
think that's an obligation I think again
not not all situations are the same not
all areas in the country are the same
there are certainly are areas of the
country where you probably shouldn't be
having church services even though even
in those situations I don't support the
government shutting down churches by
force and arresting people because I do
think the First Amendment should remain
active but I think something people
should choose not to do and in most
cases that was the choice that already
been made as to that to everything else
yeah this is this is a perfect example
but this is what I'm talking about this
is what the media doesn't want where
you've got a state like North Dakota
handling the outbreak even though
there's not much of an outbreak in their
state as far as they know turn in terms
of reported cases but handling it in in
a more targeted I think reasonable way
where you're keeping the economy going
but you're taking precautions and this
is the worst case scenario for scare
mongers in the media because if this
works for North Dakota
then people are gonna start to say well
maybe other states could have done the
same thing maybe we didn't need to tear
our entire economy to pieces for Marcus
says it's not that one person surfing
can spread coronavirus it's that if they
allow one they have to allow all some of
the examples you are giving examples I
gave yesterday of government overreach
is referring to some of the examples you
are giving are truly out of control by
the government and a power grab but the
majority are definitely not essential
people don't need to be having
gatherings on the beach right now and
police telling people to go back home
isn't a police state putting people in
jail for leaving NYC is definitely
insane however just saying be careful
with the examples you're giving because
you sound foolish with many of them one
final thing older people don't need to
be having church gatherings right now
there are other ways to worship I
practice those other ways daily sitting
in a church while simultaneously putting
older folks at risk just is simply not
worth it arresting the pastor and
threatening the shut the church down was
overstepping I agree but hardly erasing
the First Amendment surely must admit
that there are safer ways to over to to
worship right now keep up the good fight
I understand why you're trying to what
you're trying to do by reining in
government overreach but just pick
better examples of said overreach well
citing there's a couple problems here
Marcus first of all see you're doing
what a lot of people are doing with this
church issue that really annoys me
frankly and and that's you're trying to
sit on the fence where you're saying
yeah it's overreach I'm not comfortable
with it but no of course it's not an
infringement of the First Amendment well
then why is it overreach so you're
saying it's possible for the government
to overreach in shutting down churches
forcibly and arresting pastors but it's
not a violation the First Amendment I
would say it's only an overreach if it
is a violation of First Amendment then
it's not an overreach these are
synonymous terms so I don't know what
you mean by that exactly to me it sounds
like having your cake and eat it too
kind of thing or you want to play both
sides of it and in in that that has been
really irritating for me because I've
gotten so many emails for people and
forget about the emails just even
conservatives in media many of the
who I think need to be standing up and
speaking out against this instead are
trying to play that but the both sides
of the fence thing like you're doing
here so yeah I don't really like it it's
not good but it's not a violation of
First Amendment now no it's it's it's
kind of one or the other isn't it and
then you say people don't need to be
having gatherings on the beach and so
it's not about what people need to do
and we weren't really talking about
gatherings we were talking about cases
where people were going individually or
as a family unit to sit on the beach and
have a picnic or you know more than six
feet away from any other people or even
sit in their cars I mean you've got
people being arrested for sitting in
their cars and eating or something at
the beach or somewhere else you could
say you don't need to do that but that's
that's not how the government is
supposed to operate it's not supposed to
be you have a right to do the things you
need to do and anything you don't need
to do you don't have the right to do
like I would say that wouldn't when that
becomes the setup when that becomes the
way the government operates then yes we
are living in a police state when the
government says here are the things that
you need to do and you're allowed to do
those things anything else that's in
that don't need category and by the way
who decides what what's a need and what
isn't we do the government will tell you
we will tell you what your essential
activities are and if you do anything
that is not essential we can arrest you
if that's not a police state then I
really don't know what a police state
would look like if it doesn't look like
this what would it look like radical
radical idea here but maybe to some
extent you let free people make
decisions for themselves you know you're
talking about old people going to church
and they don't you want you don't want
them to be exposed well but nobody if a
church does open somewhere no one's
forcing any elderly person at gunpoint
to go to the church I would agree with
you that is probably not a good idea for
an elderly person be going to it to it
to a church gathering right now but no
one's forcing them to go so why can't
they just choose to stay home that was
already happening this is the other part
that people in your camp are not
grasping it was already happening that
most churches in the country had chosen
to take these precautions on their own
the government didn't have any pressing
need to come in even if it could be
justified based on need there really
wasn't a need because churches were
already choosing to do it all right but
thanks for the email we'll leave it
there everybody thanks for watching and
listening
have a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there